we need a modest exercise of leadership
back toward the table here I nominate
Joe of life and Mike who seemed is said
to be good at this as well
you
I'm here to preside over what is a
typical kind of inversion but we'll do
it anyway namely the very most
well-known person in the room is
introduced by one of the least
well-known people in the room so the
question is not who's judith rodin but
who's this guy who prevents you from
hearing from her my name is Don Randall
I have the honor to be the Provost of
Cornell University and the special honor
this afternoon to I won't say introduced
but to proceed judith rodin on this
podium and only briefly I assure you it
was four years ago this month that she
was named president of the University of
Pennsylvania and in that role we have
seen her fulfill a number of things that
might well have been predicted earlier
in her career in her 20 years as 22
years as a faculty member at Yale I
think what one could observe was a
constant interaction between her
scientific investigations as a
psychologist dealing with subjects of
considerable public interest both as a
scientist and as a public citizen her
work on obesity eating disorders women's
self image a whole range of subjects
have come increasingly to the fore and
she's addressed them in the scientific
literature as well as in books intended
to reach a somewhat wider audience and
so now as president of the University of
Pennsylvania she continues in that
trajectory in the context of a
university that has also taken seriously
its role in this public sphere what we
have to do more than anything this
afternoon i think is to thank Judith for
her energy and imagination in convening
this group of people to address with a
certain intellectual firepower a set of
issues that are deep concern in the
public life of the nation and the world
indeed so we all look forward very much
to Judas remarks this afternoon and let
me speed her way to the podium by
thanking her in the name of us all thank
you
actually with some trepidation that I do
this since many of you know so much
about universities and I hope that my
comments really will merely give us the
opportunity to have a very robust
conversation and I will try to say a few
things that are provocative don
certainly you know from your role as
Provost as as I do from my years as
Provost at Yale that universities are
very complicated places and I think many
of us would imagine ourselves being able
to and often as faculty members with
horror sometimes and with interest other
times sort of fantasized what it would
be to be the president of the University
and really get it right and set the
university right well as a faculty
member who was given that opportunity I
have to tell you that one should not
always one should fear getting what one
wishes for it is a very very complicated
place I want to begin by talking about
some issues that confronted me early in
my presidency because I think they set
the stage for much of what we've been
talking about I found myself beset by
calls for the university to use it's
very prodigious influence to condemn or
shut down or sanction racist or
homophobic or other forms of outrageous
behavior the university was being asked
to make our students behave to solve by
executive Fiat the social problems of
crime or litter or drunkenness or
instability to name only a few and I'd
like to tell you of three examples that
occurred in the first six months of my
presidency unrelated incidents but
incidents all that deeply offended and
disturbed various members of our
community first many of our faculty and
students were affronted by the fact that
a faculty member received research
funding from an outside foundation that
was
thought to support neo-nazi and racist
agendas second there was a students
really quite scurrilous essay on Haiti
printed in a campus publication which
infuriated the Haitian community and
finally a retrospective exhibit of
andhra Serrano's photographs at our
Institute of Contemporary Art which
included the notorious piss Christ in
which the crucifixes seen submerged in
the artists urine and clearly brought on
the predictable torrents of condom
nations the common cry in each of these
incidents and in many many others that
we all confront was why doesn't the
University stop this it was a heartfelt
demand and and I think a legitimate
question but I responded negatively to
most of these requests and to many
others that have followed on similar
issues why not because I believe in the
First Amendment although I do but
because I believe so strongly that
attempts to shut down the discourse to
civilize the debate or even to control
the sometimes outrageous behavior of
students before the fact will not bring
about the kind of reasoned and
reasonable exchange that we've been
talking about those exchanges that we
seek in fact I don't think that they
will even serve to protect those who
seek the university's protection as a
sign of respect or as a sign of
acceptance they will not reduce the
level of intolerance or in civility and
they certainly will not moderate the
ideological polarizations of our
politics and in the end I think such
measures send fundamentally the wrong
message a message that reinforces the
sense of powerless individuals and of
monolithic institutions of cultural
orthodoxy and paternalistic authority
and of ideological conformity and
political correctness none of these
messages is compatible with the vision
of free and robust expression or debate
or engagement that is absolutely
essential to an academic
immunity tempting as the mantle of moral
leadership maybe it is too often a
comfortable excuse for imposing quietude
unconformity where raucous debate and
energetic engagement should flourish and
I think both academic leaders and their
constituencies too often feel this
temptation we've come a long way to
rejecting the notion in universities of
in loco parentis and yet we seem to
still have bred a culture within our
universities and within the larger
society that makes it possible and in
some ways seem to be desirable to
transfer moral authority and
responsibility from individuals to
institutions and from institutions to
their most powerful leaders strange as
it may seem I believe that this may be
an important part of the reason why our
leaders and our institutions are not now
held in such low esteem we transfer the
responsibility to them and then we
discover to our dismay that our
institutions and our leaders are failing
failing at what I think is the
impossible task of taking responsibility
for everyone else's conduct and everyone
else's beliefs now what can universities
do after all universities play a very
unique role in our society as the makers
of new knowledge and the nurturers of
new interpretations it is our
responsibility to keep relentlessly
articulating the university as a
marketplace of ideas those of us in
universities have a special
responsibility I think for exercising
personal as well as institutional and
social leadership and certainly the
larger social dimension of that fat
comes from the fact that universities
really are microcosms of the larger
society as we all know and so from tax
policy to gays in the military from
issues of affirmative action to current
concerns about self-segregation from
adapting to the internet to Urban
Development and crime prevention one way
or another these and so many other
social issues really do play there
themselves out on our campuses and must
be addressed by the institution and
their leaders now obviously we have some
advantages that the larger society does
not have certainly the scale is often
smaller the knowledge base and level of
understanding higher and the political
pressure is somewhat less immediate
although for those of us under the
microscope they often are quite intense
and yet for all our advantages we share
many of the common characteristics that
come into play in any large society
universities are bureaucratic there's a
great deal of inertia often there's
public deafness demands for
participation and input on the one hand
and resistance to change on the other
hand likewise the same competing
imperatives come into play we question
what it is we're seeking is it diversity
is it openness is it freedom of
expression we also ask ourselves what we
value is it efficiency humane pneus
excellence and what is most important in
university is civic and community
responsibility fiscal responsibility
tradition which constituencies do we
respond to faculty staff students alumni
trustees the public the media all of
these compete really for our attention
and for our morale concurrence I think
that there's a special problem at
universities when we think about public
behavior because the issues at
universities are often exacerbated by
the energy and experimentation of youth
and by the libertarian freedom of the
collegiate environment they're aided and
abetted by the social and economic
expectations that the young they also
want it may always want to push the
envelope and break new ground but
although the strains and conflicts of
society do get reproduced on campus on a
smaller scale I think they also have the
opportunity to be clarified and examined
quite differently the reason for this is
that our universities have intellectual
strength and because they do and because
they are
worlds of ideas our conflicts often come
with reasons and with arguments reasons
and arguments that as we've seen and
talked about really tend to get stripped
away in the larger society one reason I
didn't intervene in the situations that
I talked about is that I think we can
and we have to be much more closely
engaged in universities with the
substantive heart of an issue when it
arises on a camp on a campus setting
because it's at the intellectual heart
of an issue that creative resolution
will arise and develop and so our
special ability as a university is the
ability to make new knowledge and
generate new understandings and with
that special ability it forces upon us
the social responsibility for developing
new paradigms and for thinking
differently about the issues that
confront us those pedagogically inclined
among us really know these moments as
what we've called teach the teachable
moment on a university campus when these
issues arise moments when the energy and
passion of the conflict combined with
the honesty and the skill of
intellectual inquiry to open the
possibility of a transformational
experience something maybe we should
begin to call transformative discourse
it is what the best of us routinely do
in our classrooms it's what each of us
searches for and prizes throughout our
lifetimes it's the kind of discourse
that surely can change a life but I
think perhaps can also change an entire
society how we respond to and resolve
campus campus conflicts sets up patterns
that surely will change our students and
influence them throughout their lives of
course our students do come to us as the
bearers of attitudes and as the bearers
of dysfunctions that they've inherited
from the society in which they've been
raised but if we do it well we truly are
in the business of incubating new
citizens we're in the business of
shaping them in ways that can be at wide
variance with the behavioral patterns
the attitudes that they came to us with
it doesn't always happen but it's very
very important for us to remember that
it can happen college at its best is
exactly this kind of transformative
experience and I argue insistently that
such experiences can reshape or
transform our universities and maybe
even our society as well certainly it
will come as no surprise to you that in
transforming our students were
transforming our faculty members as well
and in transforming our students and
ourselves we surely have the opportunity
to experiment with alternative
approaches to test and to tinker to
model the transformative experiences for
the larger society a note that I said
experiences and not solutions i think
that solutions really are needed but i
think there are four time in coming and
at the beginning of the work is merely
modeling the transformational experience
we tend so quickly to look for
resolution we almost did a little bit of
it at lunch time let's figure out now
what the end points are on why
struggling with outcomes as a way of
engaging in the process we are unlikely
to find the perfect leader or the
perfect institutional environment and
nowhere is such a vision more
unrealistic I think than in universities
perhaps because each year at
universities a significant portion of
the population turns over and so it
brings with it new challenges and old
challenges reborn I think like the locks
of Medusa's hair well there's no end to
the challenges but there is a process of
change and it's our responsibility to
foster that change but I believe
absolutely fervently the change will not
occur if academic leaders and their
institutions use their authority to
arbitrate the public conversation and
arbitrarily set the norms of public
conduct positive change can only occur
where there's an openness to new ideas
and new possibilities
robust engagement teaches by argument
and by example rather than by dictum or
domination the best cure for old and
dysfunctional patterns of behavior is
not prohibition but the positive
attraction of new and better modes of
discourse and interaction and it is the
academic community which should be the
hotbed of such new proposals and
possibilities doing so requires actually
very little it requires only that we
bring to bear our enormous intellectual
and scholarly resources if we fail to
bring that insight and expertise into
play we fail to live up to all of our
own rhetoric about the importance of
research and teaching and service so
confronted early in my presidency with
demands for the university to lead or
really for me to rule I hoped instead to
find a new model of leadership a new
style of leadership at least for myself
a style that would take better advantage
of the university's unique capacity to
produce and disseminate knowledge I
thought there has to be a better way to
offer and demonstrate moral leadership
than by imitating a 600 pound elephant
squashing out or drowning out whatever
behaviors or opinions it dislikes yet as
so many things when we start talking
about public behavior and when we talk
about as we have the quality of public
discourse we quickly discover another
way in which the college and university
environment unfortunately mirrors the
society at large take any contemporary
issue on campus in civility and
intolerance self-segregation I've
already mentioned sexual and racial
harassment on political correctness
misconduct and research in every case
the reality of the situation in dispute
may often be quite different not only
from how its portrayed in the media but
also may be very different from the
exaggerations and misrepresentations and
polemicist renderings that are
energizing one or sometimes both sides
to a conflict the real complexity and
the accurate representation of facts and
opinions often gets quite distorted it
was this very situation that led this
commission over a year ago to really
call for a more reasoned and reasonable
public discourse one in which real
expertise and authority have an
appropriate place one in which leaders
offer new possibilities to their
constituencies and one in which minds
and opinions might actually be changed
if my experiences at Penn and at Yale
have taught me anything it's that the
foremost task of institutional
leadership is to stimulate this kind of
robust and productive conversation and
never to shut down the conversation
before it starts to create and sustain a
discourse on our campus requires several
things first we've got to learn to
tolerate the intolerable it is the
antithesis to political correctness
hearing the hateful is an absolute free
condition to changing it when faced with
the hateful with the disagreeable with
the offensive we really can only
eradicate it or we only have a chance to
try to eradicate it if we expose it to
the light of day to open discussion and
debate when Penn Station students were
doubly offended first at the scurrilous
magazine article itself and then by my
refusal to condemn and shut down the
magazine my office instead work with
their faculty advisors to have a series
of seminars with experts across a wide
variety of opinions and political
spectra with regard to this issue this
was a dialogue that all of the parties
were quite reluctant at first to engage
in each side smoldered in the sublime
righteousness of its own position from
the point of view of the Haitian
students the demand for respect and
accuracy and from the point of view of
the student magazine obviously the
freedom of the press but there was an
extensive public dialogue
well attended difficult feisty took
several months to arrange but in the end
those who were most doubtful about the
activity actually became the major
public proponents of the approach it's
hard work creating and sustaining
dialogue but I think in universities in
particular there's no substitute for
relentless engagement we have to engage
we have to encourage others to engage
and when our energy and patience wanes
we have to reengage anew when others get
up and stomp and leave the table we've
got to help them to reengage because one
of the responsibilities of universities
is to demonstrate and demonstrate
concretely over and over again that no
matter how divided and bitter the
situation engagement with one another
even with our enemies is both possible
and the only road towards greater
committee how can this be done we're
certainly going to have much opportunity
to talk about it but I will as Richard
did give you a few suggestions as I've
been thinking about the issues recently
the first proposal I would make is that
we have got to diversify the
conversation one doesn't need to support
affirmative action to recognizing that
talking only to the converted breathes
arrogance and absolutism and orthodoxy
we cannot only talk to those people who
think the way we do one of the
prerequisites for a robust campus
discourse is a diverse campus community
but we have to be vigilant in reminding
ourselves that diversity takes many
forms it is ideological and political it
has to do with athletic talent versus
musical talent it is social and
geographic and gender as well as race
and ethnicity and universities have been
operating on the basis of this more
complex view of diversity for a very
very long time not all forms of
diversification are right for all
institutions or for all educational
missions but some form of diversity is
essential
if we expect our students to engage in
robust discourse it's important that
they experience diversity in their daily
lives not just encountered in theory or
encounter it as a part of a bureaucratic
regulation we can do it in a variety of
ways specific campus programs that have
to do with residential living campus
wide reading projects there are many
methodologies that are not draconian for
really allowing our students to
experience and relate to diversity a
second recommendation is that
universities must insist on engagement
with the surrounding community whatever
form that community takes whether it's
rural or urban poor and disadvantaged or
affluent colleges and universities I
think have never been ivory towers but
if they ever were that certainly is the
college and university of the past we
can't fulfill the mandate of social
leadership that we are describing on a
model of an ivory tower institution
community service programs
community-based undergraduate research
projects internships to name only a few
if we don't have these kinds of programs
in our universities today then I think
we fail to adequately prepare our
students for how to behave and and
debate and and be the citizens of the
world that they'll inhabit they all have
the multiple educational function of
testing ideas in practical contexts
diversifying intellectual perspectives
preparing students for the world of work
and the world of community so I would
argue that community involvement can no
longer be an interesting sideline for
our universities but really has to be a
central part of how universities see
themselves going forward into the future
third as I already mentioned
relentlessly and I mean relentlessly
articulating the vision of the
University and defending the image of
the university as a marketplace of ideas
for
if we believe this it provides the
vision that students need in order to
understand and internalize the value of
civil discourse and positive behavior it
is also the case that the university is
one of the few models in our society in
which there is a community that really
does I hope hold the values of civil
discourse engagement reflection openness
to new ideas disciplined inquiry inquiry
all of these are systematically and
persistently exemplified if nothing else
our Commission discussions to date have
demonstrated the urgent need for these
kinds of examples in the larger society
it means that all of us not only faculty
and university presidents but students
and trustees and others associated with
universities have to consistently
articulate this vision it means creating
new opportunities for non academics to
participate in the dynamic of an
academic community and that this does
serve a critical societal function that
we must take on so such things as public
programs lectures opening our museums to
the public broadcast operations even
continuing education centers again must
be seen now as serving more than just a
peripheral institutional function and
our universities we ought to be
providing incentives to our faculty and
students to participate widely outside
of their formal instructional settings
because in doing so we provide models of
an engaged citizen engaging in
constructive and civil behavior next we
have got to monitor and please our own
institutional activities this takes on
considerable importance because some of
these activities intercollegiate
athletics being one of them are powerful
instances of where institutional
leadership can be exercised or where it
fails these the powerful influence that
these activities have on our students
our alumni and the general public make
this a truly crucial institution
responsibility next I think that we need
to play a role in revisiting standards
of professional conduct our professional
schools have a special responsibility to
examine their standards of conduct and
examine the standards for discourse in
their professions with an eye not only
to their internal professional roles but
also with regard to their role model
affect their behavioral impact of their
modeling on the larger society and
finally universities have got to be more
mindful of helping other social
institutions function successfully part
of the obligation as I've said is
imposed on us by our knowledge and our
expertise but if we take that seriously
that it's important for us to help other
social institutions do their job again
this is part of exemplifying the kind of
positive engagement that creates a more
civil discourse and there are many many
examples to name only a few Boston
University taking over the bust in
public schools pan has been working to
provide administrative and financial and
computing and other forms of expertise
to support Philadelphia's efforts to try
to successfully revived itself into a
flourishing municipality Harvard in
Texas and Penn to name only a few are
offering our leaders and citizens new
models for political campaigns new
models for the public policy discussion
and legislative conduct as experts of
course we've always done some of that
but we haven't consolidated within the
university the university's role to take
that on and to understand that it is
central and not peripheral to the
leadership responsibilities of colleges
and universities in the same vein I
think we shouldn't forget that the basic
tasks of good educational practice in
any college or university what do we do
creating small seminars fostering
one-on-one interactions with faculty
providing undergraduate research
opportunities
news and opportunities for discussion
cooperative laboratory work all of these
if we think about it this way and many
more obviously teach the skills of civil
discourse and constructive behavior we
should not forget that what we do in our
classrooms and in our laboratories and
in our seminars really demonstrate civil
discourse and constructive behavior
that's not to say that we should just
keep doing what we are doing well but it
would be a very good start inputting the
creation of robust discourse at the
center of our institutional values at
universities we would demonstrate the
recognition and instantiate the
recognition that we cannot legislate
away bad behavior and in civility with
codes or policies or regulations many of
us have been attracted over the years to
a regulative approach in universities
but i think they are to find an
instrument for the task of shaping
social behavior either in colleges and
universities or in the larger society in
universities i think we have to be the
ones who discover or invent other more
positive and less authoritarian means of
influencing public behavior how do we do
that by modeling adherence and respect
for community norms than the broadest
and most positive sense and not in the
narrow and regulative sense and the only
means we have available for doing so
begins with the transformative potential
of a robust conversation set in a
diverse community of many men ease what
I like to call a mosaic of value
differences that contribute to the whole
I have never found in thinking about
universities the notion of a melting pot
a particularly appealing one I think
universities have to be a mural or a
mosaic in which the differences stand
out but work well together the goal is
not to minimize the differences but to
weave them into a tapestry that is
effective and works well that really is
greater than the sum of its parts
I think diversity will create debate it
will create conflict and controversy and
the notion of that should appeal to us
it should not be something that we fear
or try to suppress as the progenitors of
new knowledge universities have the
social leadership responsibility to
create it and to use it and to model it
but in thinking about what I wanted to
say to you I think I need also remind us
of the cold hard truth which is that the
public doesn't trust us the way that
they used to we haven't done a very good
job of making our case to the public
because in many ways the public has
become weary of institutions that fail
them and weary of false promises that
someday somehow someone really will make
it all better alas we must be I think as
Shakespeare put it masters of our fates
The Fault dear Brutus is not in Our
Stars but in ourselves that we are
underlings it's so easy in these complex
times to think of ourselves in colleges
and universities as underlings as
victims really unable to move or to
change the institutions and the cultural
patterns that surround us but clearly
the fault is not in our stars university
leaders can and must make a difference
and I'd like to just elaborate on a few
ways that I think they can we can first
of all make a profound difference by our
example nothing is more powerful than
seeing those whom we admire or respect
perhaps even those we fear behave in
ways that are worthy of emulation we can
make a difference by articulating a
broad positive set of norms of behavior
and reasonable discourse not by narrow
negative constraints we can make a
difference by making sure that clear and
consistent rewards and consequences
follow when norms are ignored or
advanced we can make a difference by
imagining and then articulating a clear
identity and a clear strategic vision
for our Institute
and for our society a vision that
individuals can internalize and
contribute to we all have a need for
context and direction and such
frameworks are among the most powerful
constraints on our public behavior we
need to provide more such frameworks we
can make a difference by consistent
implementation of our institutional
visions certainly nothing muddies the
message more than a mixed message
clarity and consistency of expression
and impression on what our colleagues
the political consultants call staying
on message but it's really important in
universities we don't always stay on
message it's an important and often
neglected virtue in university leaders
we can make a difference by clear and
aggressive leadership in response to
change circumstances by breaking new
ground and by forging new paradigms we
really can demonstrate that it is
possible to envisage a better future as
we discuss less June I think many of us
believe that that is the beginning of
affecting fundamental change our
colleges and universities have the
capacity to stimulate and to foster the
robust conversation that we all believe
must be at the heart of our 21st century
communities and so we can buy our
example promote and inculcate the civic
virtues that we have talked about the
virtues of participation and cooperation
and restraint we can by example promote
the qualities of leadership that include
positive risk-taking but I think we can
do even more we can also serve as models
of community in important respects
universities have really come to replace
many of the other mediating and
voluntary institutions that once
constituted the civil society in the
size of universities and their resources
and internal dynamics and influence
modern universities have come to
generate forms of community and
Association that weren't known in the
18th and even the early part of the 19th
entries they participate in and serve as
gateways to the wider global community
with whom we often now have more in
common than we do with people living on
the same block the same point I made
earlier about multinational corporations
and if we can actualize the potential of
universities to define civility and
community for the 21st century I believe
that universities can be truly powerful
forces for the opening of a robust
discourse and the changing of public
culture universities can set the
standards help to describe the standards
train the leaders and the citizens
demonstrate the rewards and provide the
inducements that really will foster the
more robust and diverse and civil public
discourse that we've been talking about
academic leaders and their institutions
really can make a difference but only if
we explicitly undertake the task of
building community by promoting the
robust conversation that has to be at
its heart basic academic values that we
already hold values like respecting
complexity posing substantive rather
than rhetorical questions when framing a
discussion welcoming real input and
participation and holding open the
possibility that we may be in error and
of course refraining from ad hominem
arguments these aren't only guidelines
for good public discourse but they
create in modern colleges and
universities a readily accessible model
for workable communities by modeling
this kind of public discourse and
behavior in our colleges and
universities I think we will have taken
an important first step towards
fulfilling our leadership
responsibilities and I'd like to
conclude by commenting on five qualities
that I think are essential in leading
efforts to foster both higher standards
of public discourse and also higher
standards in education and these
qualities run through and behind
everything I've said today about leaders
and institutions and
Unity's and particularly about the
responsibilities of colleges and
universities I think they're applicable
though to the tasks of leadership across
society the first and indispensable
quality of institutional and individual
leadership is courage if we don't have
the courage to lead our constituencies
rather than follow them I don't think
any of the other goals that we've
outlined will be possible second we
really do hope that our leaders have
wisdom not only the sage pneus of a
great thinker but also the pragmatic
ability to look beyond the short term
and the immediate to the world just
beyond the horizon I think that leaders
must also be passionate you heard
resident resonances of this in Chris
eglee's concept of relentless teaching
something that compelled me when I heard
him it takes passion to be relentless
and it takes relentlessness to remain
engaged when it would be much easier to
give up or give in or walk away our
leaders must also have or reach out to
find that ephemeral may be infinitely
various quality that we call vision the
ability to see and grasp the possibility
for changes that really are around us as
we discussed in June and as I think we
really all believe earn that they're not
alone in wanting to do better and in
being willing to try by offering our
constituencies clearer visions of what
the better future we might build
together look like we offer them
something that they can subscribe to
contribute to and work towards the
uplift of a compelling vision perhaps is
the greatest force that the power of
ideas can exert in motivating and
shaping and improving public behavior
finally and so importantly our leaders
and our institutions must have integrity
nothing is more corrosive of public
culture than the appearance of
corruption influence peddling dishonesty
or even just a lack of authenticity we
must hold our in
and our leaders to a higher standard
when they fail to act an accord with the
best vision of their mission and
purposes I think they destroy the very
fabric of our communal existence and we
talked about that this morning with
regard to sports as well it's no truer
there than it is in any of the glaring
episodes of misbehavior in civility and
intolerance that surround us if the only
thing required for the triumph of evil
is that good people do nothing can't we
turn it around and say that it may be
true for the triumph of the good over
the bad that we only need to act and
commit ourselves by behaving in this way
we can influence our academic
institutions and by influencing these
institutions I think we can multiply our
effectiveness a thousandfold we have the
opportunity indeed we have the mandate
to create new models of engagement and
new models of behavior we have the
capacity through education to change
people's expectations of others and of
themselves and I believe fervently that
by changing expectations we will set in
motion we can set in motion a dynamic
that really has the potential to begin
to change our society thank
I wager everyone in the room will have
something to say about that or something
to ask about who wants to be first
Eric let me just mention a few things
that that are sort of concrete issues
that arise from the kind of talk you you
gave to or things in which I think many
people feel universities are doing less
to promote and to contribute to open
dialogue they did in the past the third
is a an opportunity perhaps that exists
today that didn't seem so apparent in in
prior times I think certainly if you ask
generally today about whether university
leaders are making an important
contribution to the public discourse
even about educational issues I think
the general impression is that they're
not that there's been a real decline I'm
not speaking over ten years i'm speaking
over 50 75 years in the importance of
educational leaders in engaging in
debate even on educational issues and I
think that opens up a number of
questions about why that should be is it
that somehow people aren't interested in
university leaders as much or there are
fewer opportunities or I'm sure part of
it is that the job of a educational
leader is very much more hectic and
leaves less room for this there's also
very interesting questions about what
kinds of public issues education leaders
ought speak I speak out on I come from
University where university presence in
the past have spoken against
unionization immigration co-education
and a great many other things give you
pause about just how far afield from
educational issues one really would like
university leaders to venture in getting
it to the public debate but I do think
there is a fair set of issues about
about that I know in Boston the local
newspaper
simply because of this silence reached
out recently and said we want each
university president in the Greater
Boston area to write an op-ed piece and
we'll make available curious that the
impetus had to come from the newspaper
because it felt that there was a vacuum
there rather than being pressed to make
space for messages that university
leaders want to get across so that's the
first thing the second thing is it seems
to me most people would believe is a
trend against what you've talked about
is whether the the idea whether the the
old norms that we took for granted about
indoctrination in the classroom are as
clearly understood and as widely applied
as they used to be whether there are not
classrooms in which no there is a kind
of correctness that is imposed using at
least mild forms of authority from the
teacher and I guess I'm not aware if
that is so a very much that university
leaders of my acquaintance have done to
deal with that even though that seems to
me one of the most serious breaches of
the kind of open dialogue which you you
so correctly are pressing for but I
think the idea that indoctrination is
actually a legitimate part of the
academic mission is still held by a very
small minority but it's probably a
larger group than would have held it
that say in the in the 1950s the final
point which is a sort of a new
possibility is I think one trend that is
going on that we're all familiar with is
the the increasing sheer volume of
information often confusing conflicting
and so forth the swirls around us on
almost almost every issue and as that
takes place and as it's magnified by the
internet and a new technology which is
clearly going to add new
entrance to that I think a trend that's
already visible is going to become even
more so and that is that the role of the
interpreter the gatekeeper the person
who kind of makes sense of masses of
information that tells you what's really
worth reading or believing is going to
become more and more important and that
could be a real force / for good or for
for evil but it does suggest a possible
role for universities there is at least
one example I get from my own University
of a very innocuous role but it makes it
exemplifies the point and that is in the
area of health where you hear so many
conflicting things about this study that
study and so forth an enormous need out
there in the community for some kind of
authoritative voice that could come out
and say here is all the evidence and
hear the conflicting studies and this
looks to be a good summation of what we
know and don't know at the present time
and we found that to be enormously
successful in terms of hundreds of
thousands of subscriptions of this kind
of thing but what it was really doing
was taking a name that people trusted a
university at least they trusted it in
terms of knowing medical knowledge and
and trying to help its sifting out in
this swirling mass of information what
you could put some weight on and believe
question then would be is there in terms
of the kind of public dialogue we're
talking about is there a role for
universities to do something more of
that not in terms of telling people what
to believe but in helping to sort out
from an overload of information what do
we know and don't we know that's
relevant to this important public issues
so that we can help people who are
looking for assistance and making sense
of all this data help
them order the information so that they
can begin to think more intelligently
and more confidently about the
underlying issue let me start with the
third and say that I absolutely agree
and I think universities have often been
reluctant to take on that responsibility
of informing the general public even if
it's organizing and interpreting massive
amounts of data the Harvard Medical
newsletter maybe one notable early
example of a different attitude and what
I was trying to describe were that kind
of initiative a hundred different ways
but really believing that part of our
mandate at the present time is to engage
via our knowledge of the more general
public and to help them to understand
and sort out whether it's information of
that sort or other kinds of ideas and
and hopefully we will do more of that
with regard to your first two points I
think that it is very clear to everyone
that university presidents have overtime
university leaders have overtime really
either relinquished by intent or at
least by its absence given how busy they
are the kind of role of authority
whether it's institutional Authority or
authority in the broader community not
only on educational issues but really
beyond when that's commented upon it's
often attributed to the fact that there
are so many competing constituencies
that have conflicting motivations and
conflicting views of what is right and
wrong that the university president ever
eager to raise more funds for his or her
institution dare not offend any
particular notable constituency I think
that it's really if we allow that to
happen we really are relinquishing in a
very in a way that would be tragic the
right the role and responsibility of
university presidents
one of the just on a personal note and
one of the reasons for wanting to
convene this commission was really to
have an opportunity to be able to engage
a broader set of issues and a broader
set of publix about social issues and
ideas that really are compelling to us
in our society and we're university
presidents ought to take on some
leadership role given the opportunity to
convene colleagues such as you to do
something transformative and I think
that we will be able to do that but we
can't be gutless and we've got to be out
there and being out there is really hard
and you need to get more thick skin but
you need really to be out there I think
the classrooms have gotten politically
correct and I think that when we talk
about a kind of roiling and robust
debate we're going to have to push back
on our own faculty and on our own
students and we've got to be able to
exercise a leadership role to do that
Lonnie and I have been engaged in a very
interesting dialogue over the past
several months many of you know that she
identified that the legal method of
education typically known as the
Socratic method interpreted in a variety
of different ways seems to
differentially disadvantaged women in
the classroom relative to men and the
question of how her colleagues took the
data both emotionally and personally and
how what they did with it in terms of
changing the way they teach has been has
been a cause of great concern to both of
us so I don't say that these are easy
issues and I don't say that we move our
faculties or our students or our alumni
or trustees all at once but if we don't
try what have we given up cast
a puzzle and to harmful tendencies to
talk about the puzzle is we spoke very
eloquently on behalf of open discussion
but it is the case that no discussion is
possible unless some things are closed
so that every discussion including this
one is feasible only because we rule
some things off the agenda for example
this one surprise you at the University
of Chicago economics classes graduate
and undergraduate if you try to talk
about whether preferences ought not to
be taken as given that discussion that's
not acceptable not because of any I
think really horrible notion of
political correctness just you can't do
the form of microeconomics that people
are being introduced to if you ask
should preferences be taken as given
that's for something else in biology
classes at the University of Chicago
many other places a sustained discussion
of creationism isn't going to be
accepted in constitutional law classes
lengthy talk about why the Constitution
ought to be taken is binding that's not
acceptable now this is not to say that
these three forms of clothes closing off
the debate are bad far from it no
discussion can work unless some things
are ruled off the table you can't
discuss everything at once so the puzzle
is I don't think it's the case that any
discussion is fully open there are taken
for granted assumptions that that get
going political correctness in the most
expansive sense is omnipresent and
unavoidable and not to be deplored that
is there has to be some kind of
orthodoxy so the puzzle is when we talk
about an open discussion what exactly is
it that we're talking about I don't
really know the answer to that okay the
two bad tendencies are thing would be
good if we had a more concrete sense of
of things that were operating in current
universities that weren't working well
and let me just threw out two
possibilities one is on the Left
identity politics where we understand
identity politics to believe to be
encapsulated in the phenomenon I know at
Yale a couple of years ago
some classes law school classes were
common in which people would say as a
white male I think and then it would be
some retrograde position on rape and it
was thought that the I ascription of the
characteristic would authorize the
retrograde perfect view and in any case
the view would be that the identity
would be determinative of the argument
so that these positions were fixed an
argument wouldn't be possible across
identity so that's very destructive to
education on the right there is
something associated with Leo Strauss
and that is the great books tradition
taken taking the great books to be
authorities that have teachings that the
closing of the American mind by Alan
Blum is a famous and let me just say
polemic Lee exemplification of that view
where the the great books are not taken
as invitations to think hard about a
problem but a steady instead as
teachings that you get something
concrete from that's kind of the right
wing version I think of identity
politics and it's in a way it's it's
flip side and I think both positions
have a conception of truth which is
transcendental and that's what that's
why they're each other slip sides in any
case the puzzle is open discussion no
one would be against that but what
exactly the ideal amounts to I think is
a puzzle which is not to say that it's
not an admirable ideal it is but I think
it's more complicated to get concrete on
what what it entails exactly and the
other is to think maybe what are the
antonyms to the things you're speaking
for I guess I don't inevitably see the
opposite of closed discussion being open
discussion closed when i talked about
closed discussion i meant the discussion
of closed minds rather than the
discussion that takes place away from
the light of day and away from the
analysis of people other than yourself I
think that that's a very dangerous thing
as well but it certainly is true in any
kind of deliberation that there may be
circumstances where
everyone in the room does not serve the
outcome well and no one indeed would
have had the expectation that they ought
to be there so in a way for me that's a
straw man if that's the opposite side of
the continuum I didn't really mean that
I meant that in any discussion there are
some things that are closed off both in
terms of subject matter and position
like in this discussion we're not
talking about you know the Vietnam War
and we're having certain shared
assumptions which to question would be
not productive partly because we really
share those assumptions and we think it
would be you know if i said something
Nietzschean you would think with that
right in the so i don't it may not be
even that raising this point is
productive but but the suggestion is
that many people who I think you would
think would be disagreeing with you
would actually agree with everything you
said and say we're in favor of open
discussion too I'm Larry
I want to follow up with following
something Kass said and then bring it
back to something Robert said earlier I
think there's a fundamental ambiguity in
the idea of things being off the table
you at some point cast said ruled off
the table at another point you said
things are off the table and I think
there are very different ideas I mean it
is true a conversation proceeds with
things that are off the table but the
perception that goes along with ruling
things off the table is often extremely
destructive in the confusion about
political correctness is often that
things are ruled off the table and it's
the very ruling that people repel
against now the point when to relate
back to something Robert was saying um
Roberts question was are we able to talk
to these questions to the people and
there was an issue about whether we
should be worrying about the people but
I think there's a question that is quite
significant in relation to what you were
saying about the role of Education or
universities in this discourse at a time
when universities in skala sense the
authority of universities is off the
table everybody takes it for granted
then what presidents of universities say
is credited just by virtue of that
authority but when the authority of
universities or the presidents of
universities or institutions like this
in a sense aren't taken for grant that
authority isn't taken for granted it's
up for grabs then you have to compete
for authority through our words now it's
a great at least for academics as
academics it's our great handicap that
we speak in sentences or in paragraphs
or in page like thoughts right we have
extended and sometimes quibbling but
sort of extended ideas that we want to
express carefully that's the way we talk
and we live in a world where that talk
communicates nothing to most people that
talk is ineffective and so we oddly even
though we think of ourselves is in some
sense above this we are handicapped by
our very way of engaging
um handicapped in speaking to people so
to regain the authority that existed
when these institutions were in a sense
taken for granted as authorities for us
going to be very difficult and that
doesn't mean we don't have things to do
I'm reminded of lonnie's contribution
the very first very first of our
meetings where she described structures
we could create that would help bring
about transform transformation in the
way in which our students or people
think about things and that was using
our particular expertise but not
depending upon our ability to
communicate things directly it was using
our expertise about pedagogy here in
seeing how we can structure situations
that help people change it obviously
related to gym fish ghans work as well
so here is a place for us to imagine us
having an effect which doesn't reveal
our handicap namely we don't know how to
speak in one word bites but does
actually suggest how we could do
something out there I think that's very
compelling I think that there are the
assumption that university presidents
carry with them now the authority of
their institutions is one that we are
challenging because i think the
institutions are really losing the the
confidence and trust of the general
public and so if we are to take on this
task whatever this task is that we
ultimately decide we are well suited to
not only within our own university
community but as we reach out to the
broader communities I think we shouldn't
delude ourselves we ought to recognize
that part of what we will need to do is
to regain the public confidence in not
only because we speak differently but
because there's a real sense of mistrust
in the nature of the academic mission in
what we are teaching our students there
the the politics of the left and the
politics of the right as cast
characterized earlier are just one of
the ways in which we have turned
against one another and broaden and made
accessible to the to the broader
community a sense in which we are made
to be suspect views about the cost of
tuition views about indirect cost
recovery all of these issues are now not
thought about by the general public as
ways that universities should be viewed
as suspect so there's a larger challenge
there Larry than I think the one that
you characterized of university speak I
have a question about help for a person
like yourself and it's going to go as
follows the list of leadership qualities
that you identified passion vision
integrity wisdom it seems to me right on
the mark and in hearing company leaders
talk about what they want they often
have almost the same list and then the
second thing will say is that I want
these qualities to be exhibited by all
50,000 people that work at this company
because I can't do it alone so I really
want 50,000 leaders besides myself here
but the law then following that there's
also the quick observation that's really
hard to make that happen like I can say
we all should be owners and leaders here
but we've got 50,000 or 40 9999 who are
resistant for whatever set a reason so
as you think about our university or any
university any thoughts about how you
can carry some of these qualities
through the organization how you can
draw faculty administrators and students
into exhibiting these four or five
qualities you've identified you can't
start it without modeling it's not the
only step but it is the important first
step and so when I think about myself as
a university leader or my colleagues or
leaders in other venues really
demonstrating those characteristics is
number one and demonstrating that those
characteristics MOOC can move an
institution but also can and often do
make an individual
including the individual leader feel
quite uncomfortable then I think you
really need to vary systematically take
each level of your institution and
you're an expert in how institutions
really confronted with this have come to
the conclusion that they need to delay
you can't do it with very bureaucratic
hierarchical organizations and get too
far down in the institution so both
corporations and universities and
government as I'm sure we'll hear in a
few moments are highly bureaucratic and
bureaucratic environments really run
counter to the kind of additional
leaders that are necessary in order to
move a set of shared agendas forward I I
have never really liked the concept
follower because I'm not really sure
what that means what you need is a kind
of mutuality of leadership where
sometimes the most effective thing a
leader can do is really sit back and let
others define agendas and participate
once you've constructed a certain frame
around that and and it's not an easy
task but it is an essential task and I
guess as I said the only wisdom at the
moment is that it can it cannot be done
well in a highly bureaucratic
environment and it can't be done well
and in a highly regulated environment
and it's why as I said in my comments I
really am so opposed to regulation being
seen as a way to make things work well I
think that they're the antithesis to
things really working well in an
institution where ideas and exploration
and openness in the best sense really
need to move the agendas forward drew
lots of comments will get good
there's a certain tone I don't think
this works yes it does there's a certain
tone of nostalgia here about what has
been lost and what the universities are
confronting that they didn't have to
confront before and I'd like to
challenge that a little bit I think in a
way that relates to cass's point which
is that partly what we have universities
are suspect because they represent
changes in society particularly in the
realm of diverse communities in a way
that many other institutions do not and
people living in universities probably
are living in the most diverse
environments that they ever have lived
in or ever will live in and so when we
talk about things being off the table or
not up for discussion or we talk about
classes being more politically correct
now than they were in the past I think
we have to recognize that we are
confronting daily all kinds of
challenges and questions that were
completely off the table in the 1950s
we're talking about American history
classes and I have many distinguished
colleagues in American history here when
American history was being taught in the
1950s you didn't have to worry about
political correctness because you were
dealing with a consensus school that
didn't talk about conflict that didn't
talk about african-americans that didn't
talk about women there was no fight to
be had because the fights were all
defined off the table now happily we're
all fighting and I think that political
correctness is probably less in at least
in the context of teaching American
history than it was when we didn't even
recognize that we were all being
politically correct without knowing it
so I think that we should not just be
nostalgic for a lost past we should also
be celebrating in some sense the fact
that universities are the institutions
in the society that are confronting this
in a very direct way and in the only way
for many Americans I think who otherwise
are in very separate living situations
and operating situations and I think we
should also celebrate that the kind of
subject matter we're dealing with is
inviting these debates that we welcome
but we have to be the institution to
deal with the challenges of and that's a
very important part of this that should
keep us from longing for a world we have
lost we should instead I think celebrate
the one we've gained
Jim I have a brief comment on casas
question but then I have a question
stimulated by your presentation my
comment forecast is when he raised the
question about micro is economics
department ruling preferences whether
they ought to be satisfied or taking
this given off the table seems to me
that he said that is for something else
now the crucial ambiguity there is what
is the something else I think in a
really well functioning University the
presumptions of one course or class or
discipline or department that are open
to serious an electoral challenge the
the presumptions of one such part of the
university should be raised by some
other part of the university for example
a lot of places are some places have a
program in philosophy politics and
economics as Casswell knows where
exactly those questions would be
discussed and raised quite fruitfully
and that's indeed the special power of
interdisciplinary programs so it's it's
it's not ruled off the table for the
entire university just for the purposes
of being able to have a discussion in
one particular course it's a good fun
now I'd like to move on I think that we
had an interesting this our discussion
this morning and our working group on
community intersects a bit a good bit
with with with your presentation in the
sense that we raised or discussed some
related questions and we actually had
some disagreement a very friendly
disagreement about I guess the issue
could be put what is the main product of
the University for example it's both
people and research now if its people to
the when we're thinking about the people
after all University produces graduates
are they graduates who are being
prepared for the job market yes of
course but are they also graduates who
are being prepared for the role of
citizen I tried to say they wear but
some other some of my colleagues thought
that that was old-fashioned or there was
no longer the consensus to support that
I I think that's a very important
presumption because we're preparing p
possibly also for the public dialogue
some of them will be leaders but some of
them will just be citizens and it seems
to me that if we think of that as part
of our purpose then that impacts on how
the university does its business and on
the opportunities offered for students
now Texas has a very quaint requirement
would that that students have to take
two semesters of political science and
two semesters of history I actually
don't think it helps them that much
preparing for citizenship but I haven't
bought it because it's serves our
purposes it gives us more students than
we can handle but it raises a question
obviously the legislature this is by
state law the legislature thought it was
serving some purpose it raises the
question what would you do in order to
help prepare people for citizenship for
example some universities have have make
special efforts to provide opportunities
for internships for tutoring programs
for public service these things I think
are enormously rich probably a lot
better than political science and
getting people to have some sense of
public responsibility I also think that
from the research side and that's just
the beginning of an agenda I you can see
I haven't thought seriously about this
but I think it's one of the things we
might think about at some point on the
research side as well as the the impact
on the students who are in a sense of
product to the University they on the
research side you and I would both
remember that the debate at Yale when
they were going to get rid of the
institution for social and Policy
Studies which is a place that had its
weaknesses as well as its strengths
regardless but it was an institution
that was designed to contribute to
public policy debates and the problem
with institutions in the university
environment designed to contribute to
public policy debates is sometimes their
work is thought of as applied or not
theoretical enough for not serious
enough I think in the Yale case it was
resolved after I left but I think there
was some kind of compromise where they
kept the institution took away most of
the money so yeah but it seems to me
that
that there's a there's a there's a an
issue does that kind of research have a
role in the University I think it does
but some universities might not so
there's an issue both on the on the
research side and the student side does
the university have a role to contribute
to the public dialogue and the dialogue
among citizens let me comment briefly
because in in my prepared comments I I
hope I made quite clearly the point that
I believe it does but I think when you
educate students for citizenship and I
think we absolutely do and must educate
them for citizenship that the last way
that we want to do that is by thinking
that they're going to get it in their
history or political science courses
educating for citizenship really means
an engaged student doing whether it's
public service or independent research
so that you really can learn about the
creation of new knowledge how to
challenge information all of the process
of what we do in universities is what
trains them for citizenship very much
less is the substance of what we give
them that trains them for citizenship of
course we want them to be educated and
informed and and have knowledge but
that's the kind of baseline activity of
really creating a who will be the kind
of citizen for the future that we hope
holds the promise that is making us do
what we do in terms of universities and
I have never found the theoretical
applied schism to be very appealing
because i believe versed of all because
I now lead the university founded by
Benjamin Franklin who believed that
those to do go hand in hand and that it
is the role of the intellectual both in
the University and in the broader
society to integrate the theoretical and
the applied so I'm much more comfortable
with that at Penn I guess then I was at
Yale but it in fact I think that it is
critical I really do and I think as I as
I said earlier that we must take on that
outlet obligation we're
frontally as universities and if we keep
saying you know we're the institution
that just does it theoretically and
leave it to others to think about the
application and now i'm not talking
about applied research or going out and
necessarily solving social problems but
at least asking that our engagement be
broader and deeper with our communities
with our society and with the social
issues that our fundamental Enterprise
really can influence and make a
contribution to but nicely what you said
now is precisely the lead into what does
concern me when I listen to your you
know your beautifully presented talk you
started by giving a picture of and I
think it was received sympathetically of
the university as a neutral as a deep
politicized sort of cover over which
much variety in the case of the Arts in
the case of the conservative journal you
stood back you said you didn't stop them
from doing what they did and you
presented to me at least if not from you
it came across as a sense of of the
dispassionate the even-handed the
neutral overarching university but you
end with this impassioned plea to engage
and I think engagement is very messy I
think engagement risks all kinds of
damage to a university I'm for it but I
think it's very risky and and somehow or
another I lost in your talk that sense
that we really are bringing our
institution to the edge oftentimes and
we must take positions sometimes very on
very complicated issues as universities
in order to be properly engaged I had
unless that there was a kind of an
antiseptic
sense of how the university could engage
itself if if I conveyed that I misc
invaded and and my view both in those
three instances and my colleagues were
there and also in the comment that I
just made I think belies that I don't
think its antiseptic and dispassionate I
think that you need to create the
context in which all of these ideas
truly do bump up against each other and
and people do dirty their hands and make
one another angry and all of world is
distinct from within the university yes
to be neutral to allow that kind of
debate inside the university is one
thing but engaging issues of how to use
public resources in the area of
University of Pennsylvania wasn't even
neutral within the university and it
surely isn't neutral as it extends
beyond any behavior demonstrates a stand
and so the only neutrality is in action
and I'm arguing for the opposite of that
for really being able to engage and
deliberate and be active and take the
risk that you will offend somebody else
but when you do the response isn't to
neutralize or make antiseptic what you
originally thought it's to take it in
from the other side and let it all
really confront one another so I really
do believe just the opposite of how of
at least how you characterized it at
this moment Neil you tell me when I'd
like minutes I'd like to come at that
dilemma from a slightly different angle
in opening our study task force or study
group working group this morning I
present a dilemma to the group contained
in the phrase this is a free country
which is invoked all the time to put the
burden of unacceptability on somebody
else right that anything goes now in a
way you were invoking a liberal or free
vision of the University when you said
these things can go I mean you tried to
civilize them you try to get other
things go on but you didn't rule against
them and that they were you didn't say
they were unacceptable and take actions
to prohibit them but i think in
microcosm that reflects the same dilemma
of how do you buy what rule ground rules
and on what defense do you find anything
unacceptable i think that's an important
question and it's in some ways the
question that Stanley fish raised in the
op-ed piece that we had in our materials
on the new path situation I don't and he
condemned the university president in
that instance many of you who read the
article will recall for really falling
back on kind of free speech and
universities as being places where there
there has to be the expression of ideas
without defending substantively why that
particular conference was important as a
way of countering both Governor Pataki
and the boards of Governors I think
those are legitimate questions I tried
to say that I don't think it's about
free speech I think it's although I
believe in free speech I also think that
although you said there's a fairly
liberal view in what I articulated
there's also a fairly conservative you
because I don't believe in regulation of
this kind of institution as being in the
traditional sense of rules and
prescriptions and and mandates and
speech codes as being ways for
universities to govern themselves either
so I don't like the answer though is not
for the president to take a stand on
every issue the answer is for the
president to create an institution in
which people do take stands where they
feel safe enough to take stands where
they can come back together at the end
of that and still work together as a
community and it is really hard I know
that the traditional University has
downplayed authority as as an
institution it's not very much based on
authority it's based on persuasion and a
lot of other means and it a corollary of
not having authority in an institution
is that people will govern themselves by
individual commitment or through the
force of collegiality or other forms of
of community and one wonders whether
that that particular institutional
equation still exists no it's closer to
Michael's question done week one of the
threads it runs through this i think
poem way back very long comment has to
do with this notion of the university as
expert which often confounds our
thinking about the university because
there clearly is a domain multiple
domains in which we are experts the
difficulty is now that there's a great
deal that issue which is contesta tori
in which it's not agreed that the
university or the president of the
university can be seen to be the expert
so the difficulty for us is not how to
model the discussion about the things we
know about should you eat more fiber to
should you etc in harvard newsletter or
even how to build the rocket but it's
things as simple as what books ought
your kids to read in that sense the
great books notion itself is often
sustained by kind of view of the
university as expert aristotle was an
expert on politics and that's why you
ought to know what he said about it
rather than how to discuss something
fruitfully about which there is in fact
no
I fear we have diverges do long enough
to thank you